Trascrizione: Marco Caresia
Revisore: Federico Sangati
Buongiorno a tutti!
Sono qui per raccontarvi
una storia iniziata tanto tempo fa,
quando lavoravo in un settore,
in una realtà “a colori”,
dove l’innovazione e la creatività
non solo erano sempre presenti,
ma erano necessarie
per la sopravvivenza dell’azienda,
in un mondo dove la gerarchia
non contava più di tanto,
soprattutto quando si trattava di portare
idee nuove o risolvere problemi.
Tutti, ma veramente tutti, potevano
metterci del proprio e contribuire.
Un mondo in cui la diversità
era considerata un grande valore,
dove le parole chiave erano idea,
autonomia, condivisione, ma, soprattutto,
team, dove mi sentivo parte di un gruppo
che ogni giorno lavorava,
combatteva insieme per un obiettivo
quasi sempre chiaro e condiviso.
Poi un giorno tutto è cambiato.
Sono passata a lavorare
in aziende manufatturiere
nel mondo della produzione,
nella fabbrica.
E lì, purtroppo, i colori sono spariti.
Ho trovato un mondo diverso, un mondo
dove piuttosto che sentirsi parte
di un team, ti sentivi spesso,
troppo spesso, don Chisciotte
contro i mulini a vento.
Da solo a combattere per un obiettivo
spesso non chiaro, quasi sempre
non condiviso dal resto del team.
Un mondo dove le parole chiavi erano:
controllo, gerarchia, ripetitività,
dove il team non esisteva o quasi,
dove il contributo del singolo era sempre
molto limitato, un mondo molto vicino
alla visione terroristica dell'azienda.
L'azienda è una macchina e i lavoratori,
le famose risorse, sono degli ingranaggi
e quindi come tali sempre
sostituibili e rimpiazzabili a breve.
Un mondo dove il manager, il capo è lì
semplicemente per pianificare,
comandare e controllare.
Un mondo dove si pensa ancora che
comandare, controllare rigidamente
sia il modo migliore
per gestire un'azienda
e anche per portare dei risultati.
E qui la domanda sorge spontanea.
Io me la sono chiesta sinceramente
per molto tempo:
“Cosa c'è di sbagliato in questo?”
Ci sono un sacco di aziende,
la maggior parte delle aziende,
che sono strutturate in questa maniera.
Sono ancora qui! Forse va bene così?
Forse è corretto così?
Ci sono d'altronde tanti esempi
in cui questa gestione funziona:
pensiamo, per esempio, all'esercito.
Guardiamo l'esercito, il regno
per antonomasia della gerarchia,
del controllo, del comando,
della disciplina.
Lì c’è una persona che comanda,
una persona che ordina, e tutti gli altri
che eseguono. E funziona?
Funziona perfettamente! No? O no?
Non funziona.
Non funziona nell'esercito
e non funziona nell'azienda,
lo sappiamo tutti; lo vediamo tutti
in che crisi si trovno oggi le aziende.
Casualmente mi sono trovata
tra le mani questo libro.
Un libro che parla di eserciti
e di battaglia e che ha smantellato,
messo in crisi, una dopo l'altra,
quasi tutte le mie convinzioni
sul mondo militare,
incluso il mito del comando e controllo.
E lo ha fatto parlando di approcci
utilizzati molto prima di Taylor,
addirittura, nel diciannovesimo secolo,
dall’esercito prussiano.
Con mia grande sorpresa, ho scoperto
che sono stati adottati anche oggi,
per esempio, dall'esercito americano.
Questo libro è un continuo parallelismo
tra l'esercito e l'azienda,
tra l’incertezza della battaglia
e la mutevolezza del mercato,
l'incertezza del mondo del lavoro.
Uno dei motivi che vengono individuati,
uno dei punti chiave individuati
come un possibile motivo
di fallimento della battaglia
e anche dei risultati aziendali
è il gap, il divario che si viene a creare
tra piani, azioni e risultati.
I capi fanno i piani,
poi però le persone fanno delle azioni
che non sanno quelle che si aspettavano
i capi e non perché le persone
non sono all'altezza,
non hanno le competenze,
ma perché quello che è scontato per uno
non è necessariamente scontato per l'altro
e viceversa: quindi i risultati sono
molto diversi da quelli
che i capi avrebbero voluto.
Questo succedeva nell’esercito prussiano
ma, guarda caso,
succede anche nelle nostre aziende.
In azienda, perché?
Perché c’è questo divario?
Perché normalmente il manager in azienda,
piuttosto che il generale nell'esercito,
tende subito a spiegare il cosa
e soprattutto il come, in dettaglio,
partendo a fare dei piani
e aspettandosi che questi poi magicamente
vengano trasformati in azioni
perfettamente eseguite.
Ma, in questa ricetta del cosa e come,
manca un ingrediente fondamentale:
il perché, il perché della cosa.
Nella realtà le persone, prima ancora
dei dettagli del cosa e del come,
avrebbero bisogno di una risposta
ad una domanda semplice,
ma veramente veramente semplice, questa:
“Ma dimmi cosa vuoi, ma cosa vuoi
veramente! Really, really.”
Perché quello che succede troppo spesso
è che si parte con lo specificare
minimi dettagli, minimi particolari,
con pianificare e definire
piani dettagliatissimi,
ma si da per scontato un sacco di cose,
dando anche stesso adito a malintesi,
fraintendimenti e perdendo di vista
l'obiettivo generale.
Il vero “cosa”, il "really really".
Come facciamo quindi a rispondere
a questa domanda molto semplice?
Separando nettamente
il “cosa" e "perché” dal “come”.
Piuttosto che il “cosa" e "come” il capo
si deve preoccupare del “cosa" e "perché”
e lasciare il come alle truppe.
Quindi il generale o il manager deve
assicurarsi di spiegare il “cosa”,
ma non nei minimi dettagli,
dando l'obiettivo generale,
l'intento del "cosa" e assicurarsi
che il "perché" della richiesta
sia veramente capito.
Dobbiamo conquistare
quella collina, perché?
Perché lì passano i rifornimenti.
Quindi da una parte “cosa" e "perché”,
dall'altra parte lasciare piena autonomia
sul “come” alle truppe.
Perché è giusto pianificare tavolino,
studiare a priori il modo migliore
per vincere la battaglia e per ottenere
un risultato in azienda, ma nella realtà,
nella realtà vera, è sul campo,
in tempo reale, che le persone possono
prendere le decisioni migliori,
perché è solo lì che puoi decidere
l'azione più corretta in funzione
del contesto che cambia,
la famosa incertezza della battaglia.
Ed è solo lì che hai tutte le informazioni
che ti possono servire,
non ce l'avevi prima, a tavolino.
Questa è la teoria.
Una teoria che, tra l’altro, nella pratica
ha funzionato molto bene
nell’esercito prussiano.
Una teoria che mi ha convinto a cambiare.
Caspita, se era riuscito il cambiamento
nell'esercito potevamo riuscirci
anche noi in azienda.
Cambiare. Quindi… paura, terrore!
Perché il cambiamento fa paura a tutti,
perché il cambiamento è difficile,
perché il cambiamento ti mette in crisi,
ti allontana dalla tua zona di comfort.
E poi io, da brava matematica,
malata di mente, sono andata a prendere
tutte le statistiche che mi hanno
confortato assicurandomi
che la maggior parte delle iniziative
di cambiamento o sono fallite
o sono destinate a fallire.
Quindi... pensare!
Ho cominciato a pensare,
studiare, analizzare, pianificare,
convinta di dover essere da sola,
o quasi, a risolvere il problema
chiusa nella mia torre d’avorio,
nel mio ufficio, a pianificare il futuro,
il cambiamento.
Caduta in pieno nel trappolone
della pianificazione di dettaglio,
a priori, a tavolino del “come”.
Quel “come” che avrei dovuto lasciare
in autonomia alle persone, al team.
Mi è ritornata in mente una frase
che il generale von Moltke
ripeteva spesso alle truppe:
“Nessun piano sopravvive
al contatto col nemico.”
Quindi forse piuttosto che fare il piano,
il mega-piano termonucleare, sarebbe stato
meglio provare con un approccio graduale,
a piccoli passi, dandosi degli obiettivi
brevi, a breve scadenza,
limitati nel tempo, semplici da capire,
semplici da verificare;
quindi piccoli passi, verifica e,
in funzione del feedback, adattare
e decidere i passi successivi.
Ma tutto questo non si poteva fare
lasciando solo le persone al buon senso,
ma tutto doveva essere sostenuto
da una metodologia solida,
una metodologia, però,
che abbracciasse questi principi:
la metodologia agile era perfetta.
La metodologia agile, nata negli anni ‘90
ma formalizzata nei manifesti nel 2001,
nata nel software ma oggi ormai utilizzata
nella produzione e nelle aziende
di servizio, che, tra le tante cose,
si basa proprio su un approccio empirico,
adattativo, quindi piccoli passi,
iterazioni brevi, continuo miglioramento,
loop di miglioramento, verifica,
adattamento, decisione
sul “come” sul campo.
Era proprio quello che ci voleva.
Quindi siamo partiti prima di tutto
cercando il consenso dell'azienda
senza parlare di metodologia agile,
di dettagli implementativi,
che fanno sempre paura,
ma concentrandoci, focalizzandoci
sul “perché” di questo cambiamento,
sui risultati concreti per l'azienda,
senza parlare di rivoluzione
perché anche questa fa paura.
La rivoluzione lascia
sempre morti in piazza.
Non si può pensare di buttare via tutto.
L'approccio a piccoli passi
è un'evoluzione
ed è molto più semplice da far accettare.
Poi abbiamo lavorato sul team,
perché comunque bisognava
creare un clima di fiducia.
Non si può pensare di dare autonomia
sul come senza fidarci l'uno dell'altro.
Abbiamo cercato insieme di capire,
di avere la consapevolezza
del perché, del cosa,
quindi capire assieme la strategia
aziendale, gli obiettivi,
il perché ci venivano fatte
certe richieste, il nostro ruolo,
come noi ci saremmo dovuti
interfacciare con il resto dell'azienda.
Le procedure sono state riviste
e revisionate dove necessario
dalle stesse persone che le avrebbero
dovute usare, dalle truppe, e abbiamo
cominciato a metterle in pratica.
Nell'ottica dei piccoli passi abbiamo
istituito dei momenti di verifica formali
anche queste sempre tecniche
della metodologia agile,
quindi teniche specifiche proprio
nell’ottica dell'adattamento continuo.
Condivisione, massima trasparenza.
Abbiamo messo in giro per l'ufficio
in posti visibili di passaggio
tabelle con post-it per rendere visibile
a tutti le attivita, le pianificazioni,
lo stato dei progetti, i ritardi,
i problemi, senza nascondere niente.
Abbiamo fatto un cambiamento a 360°.
In conclusione, siamo alla fine
di una bella fiaba, io ho ritrovato
il mio arcobaleno di colori.
No, o meglio, non ancora.
I primi i risultati però concreti
per l'azienda li abbiamo visti,
li abbiamo già condivisi,
le prime battaglie le abbiamo vinte
e in tutto questo le persone sono
sicuramente più consapevoli
del proprio ruolo, si sentono importanti
nel raggiungimento
di un traguardo in azienda
e sono sicuramente più motivate.
Le persone più motivate lavorano meglio
e i risultati si vedono.
Diciamo che ci sentiamo un po' meno spesso
Don Chisciotte perso nella nebbia.
Sappiamo che la strada è ancora lunga,
fatta di piccoli passi, di adattamenti
continui in un ambiente ostile, difficile.
Il percorso non è
e non potrà essere rettilineo,
per tutto quello che ho
cercato di raccontarvi.
Ma, io un po' di colore l'ho ritrovato.
Lo abbiamo ritrovato e la cosa bella
in tutto questo è che ho avuto la conferma
che le persone, in qualunque ambiente,
in qualunque settore lavorativo,
ci possono sempre sorprendere in meglio.
Con idee nuove, con soluzioni diverse,
ma sempre, la maggior parte delle volte,
proprio quello che cercavamo. Grazie.
(Applausi)